[Music]
to be famous in the world of esports
it's safe to say you need to be able to
appreciate a good meme
true super stardom in this world doesn't
take place in big press conferences
red carpets or glamorous photo shoots
in esports you've gotta master the art
of reddit
the combination of being absolutely
incredible at your game of choice
while simultaneously not taking anything
seriously
i dated a girl that went to high school
with you shroud
she saw me watching your stream one time
and she told me about the time she slept
with you
word on the street is that you've got a
fat grow up to me
oh no maybe nobody in esports history
embodies this more than the king of
reddit himself shroudy rowdy
from clutching on the biggest stage with
cloud9
to the top of the twitch charts
this is his story
shroud joined cloud9's counter-strike
global offensive roster
on september 1st 2014 after the
organization acquired complexities
roster
which featured shroud as a stand-in
shroud was a streamer who had been
competing in esea qualifiers
with exertus esports and manajuma during
2013 and early 2014.
it was during this era that he impressed
the eventual cloud9 roster
and landed himself a spot on the squad
the main
way i kind of got scouted was i streamed
a lot streaming is actually a good way
for
people to scout i guess because they can
watch your stream
i didn't even know i was going to join
the team
i just finished the regular season with
manajumas and then
a week a week after dborn messages me
and says hey
do you want to join complexity which is
cloud9 now and i was just like
of course yeah from his beginnings in
mississauga canada
shroud was bred to play games he lived
with his father
who built computers obsessively and
introduced shroud to games as a child
no i love games i love games i love
computers i
i build every single computer we own and
um
since he was really tiny i was putting
him
on my lap and you know let him do
whatever
and then i introduced him to
counter-strike because i like that game
and uh he picked up so quickly that
after a couple of months it was
pointless for me to play with him shroud
started streaming while pro
counter-strike was still a pipe dream
for him in 2011.
he'd actually lost interest in cs during
source
but his fps fire was rejuvenated when a
friend gifted him
csgo on steam a year or so later
shroud was a huge fan of summit 1g on
twitch
and wanted to give streaming a try so i
first
started streaming oh yeah i was probably
like 20
11 ish i didn't have any viewers i
streamed probably for a year with
one viewer and that was myself and the
reason i started streaming
was because of summit i was watching him
play and he had you know like a couple
hundred
um viewers and it was just how much he
streamed and like inspired me he quit
his job and whatnot it was just
i was like i want to do that it was a
long time before he saw
any success on the platform but his pro
career in cs go
allowed his stream to grow shroud made
his land debut with cloud9 in 2015 at
esl
esea pro league season 1. shroud and c9
won the n a bracket
and then finished second to fnatic in
the international finals
they have got no more grenades there is
no kit though on cloud9
they've got almost no time if they die
now he jumps against the shot and that's
probably going to be the round
shroud can't do a thing here flusher
thinks of a quad kill in return
this has gone horrifically wrong for
cloud9 they had this game in the back at
15
11. all they needed to do was close it
out and once again
they have struggled to finish off the
map and pronax is going to put up a very
good grenade here they're going to walk
right into it the full up molotov to
burn up a little bit more damage and
sean goes down this jw with the kill
is talking great for fnatic they've done
it
time and again two major championships
and here it is
they are your victors here at esl esta
pro league season one
in an era where north america was
considered the minor leagues of
pro cs c9 making it to the pro league
finals
was huge cloud9 summer run in 2015 was
big for nacs
and shroud was quickly building a
reputation for being one of the most
talented
players in north america cloud9 looked
at shroud and they saw potential they
liked his decision-making they liked his
positioning
and they said okay if we can develop
this guy if we give him more experience
we like how he's playing the game but if
we give them more time to develop with
good teammates those frags will come the
frags aren't the issue for them they saw
how stellar his aim was how pinpoint and
precise it was
i love shot of death and i think he's
one of the best players he's one of the
best players i've ever played
man probably the best best pure gamer
i've ever seen in my life
shroud is literally like the best aimer
in north america like hands down i feel
like with when he's rifling
like you could watch this kind of stream
pull off the most ridiculous
4ks in 5ks after their esl pro league
finish in 2015 cloud9 and shroud's next
big finish
was at dreamhack bucharest in 2016.
once again they were the runner-up
falling to another one of the world's
strongest teams
in virtus pro on top of the balcony
position they're going to try and bait
it automatic though neo's got the first
shot automatic still in behind the hut
he's still not peaked on this he's got
to try and
cut them out for the broken wall he does
get one but now it's just him remaining
and he's on to 16. he's gone
your dream hack open champions in a very
very convincing tournament these guys
cease to stop and easy against
americanas
once more they dominate usa during the
latter half of 2016
shroud and cloud9 finally won a big
tournament now the one thing about
dropping through is they could push to
be as a result but they want to contest
stewie
who gets one it's called zero bomb down
automatic in a one versus one and he's
got no idea where automatic is
he's rotated all the way to long and
cold might get caught
he's looking down toward the door he's
in the open automatic
to give cloud9 season four
c9 defeated sk gaming in the finals of
esl pro league season four
to bring a significant title to american
counter-strike
that fateful summer of cloud9 was capped
off
with a bang and this team was
single-handedly making a case
for north america's potential to compete
on the international stage
at this point shroud had been relegated
to more of a supporting role
than his early days of wowing on stage
with his aim
i'm trying to help those guys [ __ ] be
the all-stars
i'm no longer the all-star for those of
you that
don't already know my role isn't to
[ __ ] make plays and all that [ __ ]
it's to help them make plays i'll die
for them i'll flash for them i'll
[ __ ] smoke for them i'll do anything
for those guys
i don't care how much [ __ ] anyone's
going to give me with the injection of
youth into c9's roster
shroud was doing a lot of lurking
in-game and mentoring the new players
the addition of stewie2k and automatic
to the classic c9 core of shroud
nothing and skadoodle proved that an
american team
could play at the highest level but the
real test was competing at a big
time cs go event where all the best
teams
showed up a bit of damage but not too
much and he's gonna go for the fight
again making it a double he's out of
bullets otherwise that would have been
way more
trout and skadoodle and that's the end
69
in favor of cloud9 as the bomb goes in
kanji and henny
know this one could be all that over
it's certainly looking that way
there's one more opportunity but that's
just gone
so it's just henny with the scout five
opponents and there it is cloud9
eliminates
left that's the big deal they're gonna
have to hit the head shots pure and
simple the flash to lead the way dennis
spots the man skadoodle get a shot in
the face but luckily for him he survives
and that buys enough time for nothing
and skadoodle
it all comes down cloud9 will be playing
on the stage tomorrow
cloud9 just barely squeaked into the
elimination rounds at three and two
after opening with back-to-back losses
to ninjas in pajamas
and nadas vincere in the bracket stage
there were three north american hopefuls
c9 liquid and optic
but after cloud9 got their revenge on
nip in the quarters
they were na's last hope cloud9's
cinderella run continued when they faced
off against na'vi
they showed up in a big way and trounced
navi
in a 2-0 victory a lot of damage delta
flame you got to step out wins the fight
but then sets it up for shroud to step
in
and pick up two kills of his own edward
the last man alive
and it's not gonna be good enough shroud
the hero three kills
who's gonna look the right way at the
right time
and it's happening nothing he doesn't
and he just stands up
ice cold 16-14 cloud9 are in the grand
finals of esl one cologne 2017.
a north american team was about to play
david
against a goliath in sk gaming and there
was a 100 000
grand prize hanging in the balance they
can actually wrap through
taco as well as gonna push out from
apartments they didn't have that last
time they didn't have that string to the
rose to automatic downwind shroud has to
respond nothing saves him and he steps
up in the pit cloud nine fine five he's
gone anyway taco's gotta give up on the
boost
he's still looking above fighting the
ball but no they don't see him shroud
looked completely over top of him tacos
dropped the bomb down for skadoodle to
have to get back in a one versus
three good shot on fallen knows the
cold's up close or excuse me taco is
rather
this could be the final player of the
tournament cloud9 trying to do what they
can as they edge towards the b-side
is now where they're so in the open even
if they threw one they'd be able to push
through it before it landed
based on the angle it's thrown so phelps
could go he doesn't even need to wait to
go they walk into it it's lined up and
it's done
and sk for the home of the organization
will take a second straight esl one
cologne championship
cloud9 might not have won at all but
they proved once again
that they had what it takes to compete
at the game's highest level
shroud was instrumental in c9's run in
cologne
particularly in the bracket stage when
it counted most
of course after shroud left c9 they went
on to become the first north american
team
to ever win a major title but his impact
on that run in boston
is notable nonetheless shroud was a key
cog
in what would come to be america's cs go
darlings
and without his consistency game iq and
commitment
they wouldn't be the team we know today
even stewie admitted that shroud was one
of the things that made him want to be a
pro
so when i watched like streamers like i
used to watch mike play a lot and i
see him do certain aim
like a certain way to aim then i would
try to mimic it i would try to like
steal people's playstyle and just like
add it to my own
throughout his career as a pro player
shroud balanced his career
with the growth and development of his
stream
[Music]
what could be better right streamer by
night pro rifler by day
but at times the counter-strike
community were critical of shroud
for his career juggling act unluckily
for uh shroud he unfortunately had
not the strongest performance this
weekend in the summit
and he got roasted it looks like a
little bit by the community because he
he
streams other games [ __ ] doesn't
just play cs every hour of the day
when his performance waned or cloud9
were struggling
fans wanted to see shroudy practicing cs
not playing other games on stream dude
[ __ ] like literally [ __ ] my mods feel
free to [ __ ] ban anyone just crying
about other people and what other people
say
like i don't i don't care to see that i
don't care to see
any of that after all this what do you
still like playing counter-strike
no dead game when people criticize pro
players for not purely just practicing
whatever their sport or field or game is
all the time so
at the moment the instance that's really
brought this up to me
is the case where people are really
critiquing shroud
over the fact that he'll stream like pub
battlegrounds where the [ __ ]
the idea that like you know he's doing
that instead of practicing and that's
why he's not some top player whatever
you haven't seen the cs reddit shroud it
used to be all
praise for you now they hate you
with that said even at the height of his
career shroud was more popular
as a streamer and personality than as a
pro player
and after c9's run in cologne in 2017
shroud started to focus more than ever
on streaming
and this aligned nicely with the
explosion
of one of the biggest games of the last
few years
playerunknown's battlegrounds was
released in march 2017
and by the time the summer rolled around
was taking the gaming world
by storm a few months prior to his
choice to step down from c9
shroud hopped into pub g and
well he was unbelievably good at it
[Music]
boy
little counter strike action baby
all dead all done i'm running this field
knock down knock down look at my elbow
and then in august 2017 shroud
stepped back from the team starting
roster and decided to focus
entirely on his stream i messaged jack
and i was like hey
jack's the owner sina by the way i was
like hey uh i kind of want to step down
i would love to be your guys's backup um
i want to see where full-time stream
takes me
it felt like it was about time for me to
go you know
this whole pub g thing came out i've
enjoyed pub g so much and i'm like
slowly losing my passion to compete
i just want to relax sit here and game
during that same august
pubg had its biggest streaming month the
game was streamed to an
average of around 100 000 viewers at a
time
as shroud leapt into streaming and left
the safety of his pro career behind
he and pub g were attached at the hip
and both were only getting bigger in
august 2017
the first month he streamed full-time he
averaged just under 20 000 viewers at a
time
since then he's never averaged less and
peaked in april of 2018
with an average of 40 000 viewers
[Music]
i literally like shaking
shut keep it lit like this is crazy
i'm about to be at 7 hundred subs you
guys
oh my god the subs oh my god i look over
to my right and it's just
it's just a wall oh my god
professional esports and streaming have
operated adjacent to one another for
years now
it's not surprising for your favorite
pro player to also dip their foot into
twitch
to help build their brand but as of late
we've seen streamers whose twitch
personality
surpasses any fame or fandom they'd
achieve as a pro player
figures like ninja and dr disrespect
have never been in the forefront of any
major
professional esport but have become some
of gaming's
biggest stars and shroud wanted to give
himself
a chance at that at being more than an
above-average pro counter-strike player
that is pristine could be peaking though
i think for the two months
thank you guys so much for all the subs
by the way idiotic for the three months
[Music]
[ __ ] simon thank you for the two
months julva thank you
nocturnal genius thank you i can't
[Music]
even while he was a pro player shroud
was always known as the king of reddit
but since his commitment to full-time
streaming
he's earned that nickname tenfold
wait or not i think yeah
watch this watch
[Music]
other top broadcasters fill up your
computer screen with music
gimmicks and boisterous entertainment
but shroud
is just a straight up gamer and he's
damn good at
every game he plays okay um
[ __ ] that was my last bullet too
what the [ __ ] i always pick shroud's
mind because i consider shroud
the best pc player on twitch but when
you want to talk about pc and pc
precision
i think shroud is it's just
miles in front of anybody in a lot of
ways
shroud has become a sanctum for the old
guard of esports fans to kick back
and hang out he hasn't adapted to the
overly boisterous style
of other massive streamers like ninja
shroud is just a great gamer
who streams every day and he owns that
brand
and it's that rock solid brand that he's
built his community around
shroud has become the place to go for
esports fans
redditers and anyone looking to watch
high-level gameplay
and grab a laugh hundred dollars to the
person who takes out adam right now
okay why the heck
he's still he's still alive
this is a fun game
do dude what cements his style even more
is his consistent support of small
streamers
he's found a way to build content out of
helping people
we're gonna host a random runescape
small
streamer okay what the [ __ ]
shroud has hosted you with 30 317
viewers
what what
type 1 diabetes and has
five-year-old daughter show her some
twitch prime love
give her that twitch prime [ __ ] love
right now
oh my gosh what the [ __ ] shawn's like
what's
gonna help her medical bills i don't
want the first thing
just go [ __ ] i am just go you being
ridiculous
just go just do it oh my goodness
look at all the twitch fries i've never
seen so many subs in my life
what in the world look at all the subs
you guys are incredible dude holy [ __ ]
no matter the game shroud's viewership
stays strong
something that's unusual for all but the
biggest streamers
shroud has recently streamed cs go pubg
fortnite realm royale and world of
warcraft
somehow he's just great at every game he
tries
overshadowed by his growth as a streamer
is the fact that shroud
has become one of the best pub g players
on the planet
but i was watching shroud last night
played battlegrounds
first person
the guy is amazing
he might be the best player in the game
recently
in a team tournament shroud and another
popular streamer
chad took down 9 out of 10 winner winner
chicken dinners in the event
oh my god boys gg nine wins
should be ten ten wins one second place
with a man down i'll take that [ __ ]
in a lot of ways the popularity of
fortnite has epitomized why shroud's
viewers
are so loyal to him he knows he could
give in to the hot new thing
but in typical shroud fashion he stayed
loyal
to pubg he's not trying to be like ninja
or ride the fortnite wave into
mainstream success
shroud has truly lived the esports
roller coaster
he's evolved from north american
counter-strike golden boy
to reddit's darling right before our
eyes
there's no question that there's a long
way to go in esports fight
to legitimize itself in the mainstream
and offer
long-term career options past the upper
echelon of each game but if there's a
benchmark to follow when it comes to
remaining relevant throughout your
career
in a world where there's new games
popping up left and right
shroud is it he's adapted
he stayed loyal and he's still here
growing and leaving his mark on every
aspect of this community
we love
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button